We haven't heard much from Kellyanne Conway in the national media after that pathetic embarrassment
of the so called Bowling green massacre that of course never happened and doesnt exist that she mentioned on tv
she mentioned that and then basically stopped doing national media
I don't know if she's been in timeout long enough that now she's out of it
Or if things are just getting so desperate for the trump administration that they figured hey, let's put her back on TV
But she appeared on a number of programs over the weekend including on Fox news to talk about the growing trump Russia scandal
Let's start with her appearance on Fox and friends
She went on Fox & Friends to talk about how it's just no big deal that
Donald Trump Junior met with a russian lawyer and a russian lobbyist and blah blah blah blah blah and I want to prepare you for
What we're about to see in here. She is about to move the goal posts and use projection and
Blame Hillary to try to distract from what's going on?
But she moves the goal posts herself by accusing others of having moved the goalposts
Sit down get the kids out of the room because this is really really bad. We don't want to listen
I'd show them janet Jackson's breasts ten times before I showed them the atrocity that I'm about to show I'm not even going to watch
Yeah
Pat you pat's leaving the room himself here is clip number one of Kellyanne Conway's immediate implosion over the weekend
Even the goal posts have been moved. I mean we were promised
systemic hard evidence of systemic sustained
Furtive collusion that not only interfered with our election process, but indeed
Dictated the Electoral outcome and one of the only people who says that seriously these days is still hillary Clinton
And I one believes it. We know why she lost
It's obvious and and frankly you know when I was campaign manager in those last several months
I you know when I needed negative information about Hillary Clinton. I don't have to go very far. I looked at infiltrate Clinton
Yeah, so listen they've been swearing up and down that they never met with Russians
They never talk to Russians russians didn't help him with the campaign in any way. That's now undeniable
They've moved the goalposts to the Collusion wasn't illegal and instead
she says that it's others who are moving the goalposts then she gets asked a specific question by the bundling Steve doocy and
She goes back to Blame Hillary Clinton, but Kelly
I'll call you up all the time and say hey, I got some dirt on her and would you take a meeting with them?
The President said yesterday that kind of occurrence happen all the time
Well it does but in the case of Hillary Clinton
It was fair to say yeah
Let's talk again about Hillary Clinton now contrast this with what Kellyanne Conway herself had to say in January
Listen to how definitive. She was here
Did anyone involved in the trump campaign have any contact with Russians trying to Meddle with the election?
Absolutely not and I discussed that with the president-elect just last night those conversations never happened
I hear people saying it like it's a fact on television. That is just not only inaccurate and false
Is the president what it does undermine our democracy?
Nobody was involved there was no contact. We now have proof in writing
So this is bad enough, but if you can believe it it gets even worse
She then went on ABc's good morning. America and claimed with a straight face that the real problem here is
James commis leaking of information
that's the problem according to Kellyanne Kellyanne what we have to go the
Information was sought from the campaign and those denials were allowed to stand for many months. That's the bottom line. Thanks very much
You're done. I wasn't in the meeting
I was in the meeting but people amended their disclosure forms, and I think the big bombshell this morning is Jim
Call me disclosing confidential information
Conversations he had with the president
I stated quote private memos that's something Americans should release oh yeah focus on that these are liars of the highest order this is
shameless dishonestly and at this point
It's indicative of panic and a question for a lawyer would be at what point if any legally speaking?
Do Kellyanne Conway's persistent public lives become part of the cover-up would you be willing to have a serious conversation?
With Kellyanne Conway cuz I don't think I would be able to learn oval projection shifting the goalposts
I mean, there's no intellectual honesty there
And we can't even agree on what the facts are because she has alternative fact
I would have a serious conversation with her if she were capable of doing that and less substantive
But just as wacky here is Kellyanne Conway doing rhyming while holding signs up on Fox news
I just want to review in case you run out of time, and this is how you see it so far
This is to help all the people at home. What's the conclusion?
Collusion no we don't have that yet. I see
Illusion and Delusion, so just over clear everyone's forwards conclusion Collusion, no
Illusion Delusion yes, I just thought we'd have some fun with words assessing these grover
where is the day perhaps yeah when the
Indictments come in
I hope that she's going to spend her time on something other than picture sign of
Words on how to fit whatever you would even call this nonsense. This is insane making it easy for the Fox news audience to understand
Yes, she had to speak for the lowest common denominator
Folks, what is going on here? I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David Pakman show follow me there today's program is made possible by Taga
Dabbe the hosting specialists offering a range of flexible hosting packages including dedicated
Vps, and cloud server options as well as custom server solutions and uk-based
Colocation services
for your business or project
Taga Dad's Web hosting services support a wide range of customers and businesses worldwide including
Bloggers tech startups financial traders gamers web developers and more and Taga Dad has a really user-friendly
Interface, so you don't have to worry about being super tech savvy they can automate almost everything you need for total ease of use
They are really proud of their team of expert hosting specialists who are also their support team?
70% of their business comes from repeat orders and
Recommendations with a growing number of people interested in moving their businesses and projects to the cloud
Taga Dab is currently offering our viewers and listeners a
Twenty British pound free credit about twenty four us dollars to
All customers signing up to give you a chance to try the service
This is a limited availability offer
First-Come first-served for viewers and listeners of the David Pakman show to take advantage of it. Go to sign up cag adapt calm
/t DPs, and use the offer code
TDPs 20 all one word all lowercase during account registration